you worked on two Batman films
completely different beasts the
superhero genre back in the 90s compared
to the way it is today if you've what
was it like working on those films back
then uh you know it just it was a
different time
you know it's complicated because you
know it's fine I think in a funny way
this show that Jeff Jones and I created
Titans is kind of my apology tour for
Batman and Robin because you know it was
it was heady and extraordinary and
something I you know I I'm a deep deep
deep deep deep old comic book fan and so
the opportunity to get to them and have
to do happen to play in them was amazing
and as you say it was a different time
so like things didn't last that you
really wish had so like for me
you know people may know this Robin
Batman Forever actually was all about
Bruce finding this his father's Journal
and in it it said Martha Bruton Martha
and I want to stay home tonight but
Bruce insists I'm going to see a movie
and so you discovered that it was all
him he's been holding the guilt all the
way through about being responsible for
his parents death nothing that makes the
cut because we shot it and then we
tested it and audiences were not
interested in the psychological
component of the drama at that all right
that was not what they were coming a
comic book movies for I mean I worked I
wrote I wrote after Andy Kevin Walker on
this version of Batman vs Superman with
Colin Carroll was cast as Batman Jude
Law was cast as Superman where peg
Pierson was directing we were in prep
and it was the darkest thing you've ever
seen it was you know starting with
Alfred's funeral and Bruce was had
fallen in love renounce being Batman the
Joker kills his wife and then you
discovered it was all a lie that bad
just the the love itself was constructed
by the Joker to break it like so it was
this wonderful life it was a time where
you would sort of be able to get these
stories together in script form but they
couldn't quite land in the world like
ether somehow somehow the expectations
of the object whether they be audience
or corporate or directorial or they
weren't the one it wasn't landing quite
in the way I think we imagined when we
would put them together on the page and
that as for Batman and Robin and that
one just confuses me I mean we didn't
mean for it to be bad
I swear that was nobody was like this
will be bad like we were really thinking
it was gonna I mean here's the irony if
there was a real that was sort of put
together halfway through where it
actually looked you know dark in a
interesting way and then it just is what
it is you know we I'm sorry I mean I
think we're all sorry I mean
but by the way just to interject I've
spoken to a lot of people and I've
learned a lot about the craft of
filmmaking since with my time at
Collider and it's true though nobody
sets out to make something bad everyone
is putting their heart and soul and yes
it's a year or two of your life you're
trying your hardest and sometimes you
know it just doesn't come together and
sometimes from what I understand like an
OK script becomes this great move
because about yeah it is alchemy I
always used to say it's like painting by
lightning you know it's like a mural and
you're painting and you're just every
time the lightning flashes you paint and
then the Sun rises you're like or you're
like ooh but you know um it is it's
magic that's the obviously if it were
predictable
if it were if it were manageable in any
real way then we'd only make good movie
right in the same way that we don't you
like the same car is a good cup you know
like X you don't typically have a lot of
bad cars you have a lot of movies that
don't work and and that is the terror
and the joy because you don't work any
less hard on the ones that don't let you
know um I really what year was that
movie you were saying the Batman
Superman thing that you were working on
I don't remember what hear that it's
like 2001 there was a day it was right
after me it was right after a beautiful
mind I know this because both Ron Howard
and I were discussing projects that we
had right after the Academy Awards that
didn't go forward and we were both like
well we can't take it personally today
like today you're just gonna realize it
doesn't matter where you are in your
career it's gonna slip through your
fingers sometimes so I was probably
2001-2002 somewhere there because what I
what I really think that Warner Brothers
DC have done great recently as the idea
of these one-shot movies you know what
Todd Phillips did with Joker and I
really hope they pursue this where you
can tell these one-shot films and you
know it sounds to me like the
you were working on was just about you
know maybe 18 to 20 years too soon
it was a it was it was really world's
finest you know in a kind of dark and
interesting way and I think could have
been lovely and you know on the other
hand none of me is sad that Nic Cage is
Superman didn't get made so I guess in
that whole period of time there were
winds to be had and losses to be avoided
you know completely you obviously Matt
Reeves and Robert Pattinson are working
on Batman now what you are looking at it
from afar or what's your take on on the
two of them paired up look I am Matt
Reeves is I think so insanely talent and
I think Robert Pattinson is terrific but
for me the key to this is Matt like have
you ever seen the pilot of felicity yes
I mean it's Matt directed it JJ wrote it
it comes in this extraordinary way and
from that I have admired Matt as
director I just think he's if he's
literate he's articulate emotionally he
cinematically very for a candy virtuosic
like for me I I can't wait to see her